so Margo is it true that you had a
sleepover like for the cast before the
movie we had a Bobby sleepover it was it
was as fun as you as it sounds yeah it
was your welcome idea yeah it was
Greta's idea I can't take credit we all
went to like claridges which is a really
gorgeous hotel in in London we all like
shared beds and like wore our pajamas
and ordered room service and played
games and found out that America is like
exceptionally competitive
I am extremely competitive and nobody
told me that it was a sexy Barbie
sleepover so everybody was in like
really pretty silky nightgowns and I was
in like the most Grandma floral twin set
you could imagine how simultaneously
looked like an old lady but a
five-year-old at the same time it was
the cutest and she's 13 while she's
yelling at you while she's screaming at
you but it was very it was it was so
Charming I mean she was like this cutest
little thing you'd put like a toddler in
to go to bed and then she was like
rousing at us for not knowing the rules
yeah
if you're not gonna compete
another of your kids was Ryan Gosling so
what was it like to work with him he's
so talented it was again as amazing as
it sounds yeah he is just he's funny man
I got very like funny to meter in
Chinese he is the most comedically
gifted actor and like I think he's just
so known as being such a brilliant
dramatic actor that people will
sometimes like oh yeah he is really
funny he was funny in that thing in this
movie he's funny on like a completely
different level I I ruined like all his
takes because I just laughed for them I
would I actually now watch like the the
edit of the film and I can see Greta
cutting away before I laugh and my like
corn is in my mouth like and then she
cuts back to him because because he's so
serious but it's so funny he's so funny
oh and I I agree he's going for it in
this movie it's amazing
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
guys I'm going home